ich finde dass die scheiß aus hh
wie scheiße siehst du denn aus hässlich
wer findet auch das scheiße aussieht
warum machst du das sieht richtig
scheiße auch man leute ich hab jetzt
wirklich lange hin und her überlegt und
bin jetzt wirklich zu dem entschluss
gekommen
durch euer ganzes positives feedback com
wir bringen es schnell in trotz
voll schlecht oder als wenn ich die
wieder ab basiere leute ich lasse jetzt
erst mal ein halbes jahr dran müsst euch
dran gewöhnen ein spaß man aber mein
video gestern ich hab mir gestern abend
so die kommentare durchgelesen und ich
fand es echt witzig zum teil und habe
mir gedacht komm suchst du doch einfach
mal die lustigsten kommentare raus oder
die kommentare die am meisten gepusht
wurden und kommentiert sie ein bisschen
weil ja findet ihr die haben sich schon
verändert oder immer noch genauso
schlecht so also ich hab die ganzen
kommentare hier abgespeichert und wir
schauen einfach mal im ersten positiven
kommentaren du wirst immer mehr zur
[ __ ] alter tja meine ich werde
immer mehr zu [ __ ] jeder meint
einer ich werde immer mehr zu [ __ ]
er übrigens ich werde immer mehr zu
[ __ ] was ja auch sagen wollte ich
werde immer mehr zu [ __ ] ich
verstehe eigentlich gar nicht wie man
diese beiden sachen miteinander
verbinden kann ich meine ich hab doch
nie schwulen gesehen der dread locks hat
oder raster teile oder was ist der
nächste kommentar kommt von alex und er
schreibt also nicht von mir sondern von
alex video bei schamanen würde das
glaube ich geil ausnehmen dreadlocks
kann man erst ab 7 cm machen habe ich
gehört und ich hoffe mal nicht dass
deine haare im intimbereich so lang sind
weiß doch tut mir das mädchen sehr leid
welches sich als erstes kommt zum
nächsten kommentar ein guter und
langjähriger freund moritz schreibt
einfach so nach smiley ich finde wir
rufen einfach mal kurz an und fragen so
was ihr von meinen haaren hält was geht
ich wollte mal kurz fragen was du von
meinen haaren hält ja ist schon komplett
finde ich die volkshaus oder nein spaß
man nicht findet die sind erst in zwei
wochen so finish das intro gummibänder
drin also die müssen raus und dann sind
die automatische länger und dann weißt
du nicht ich habe dein kommentar gesehen
und ich mache hat ein video wo ich die
kommentare dazu beim volk deswegen habe
ich dir jetzt angerufen willst du willst
du das auch mal machen so wenn ich sage
bei 20.000 likes macht moritz
okay okay sagt hunderttausend jetzt
niemals kommen ok bei 100000 like macht
sich moritz gab detlef so läuft nächster
kommentar der be schreibt uhr gott ich
mag dich ja eigentlich echt aber müssen
jetzt alle jungs ob justin bieber machen
erst machen sich alle jungs blonde haare
was er ja auch gemacht hat und jetzt
auch noch die dreadlocks also nicht böse
gemeint du kannst machen was du willst
vielleicht sollte das einfach nur trend
seien aber naja du siehst auch nicht
scheiße ok bist ja sogar ein positiver
kommentar danke schön aber ich habe auch
wirklich oft in den kommentaren gelesen
dass ich irgendwie nach machen oder so
wo ich mir denke alter mann dann ist
youtube de könnt unter jedes video
schreiben das ist nachmachen von
irgendwas falls es immer schon mal gibt
auf youtube gibt alles schon mal nur
weil sich irgendeinen xy youtuber schon
mal solche harten gemacht hat heißt es
nicht dass man dem direkt nach macht nur
wenn man das schimpfen und das auch
haben will dann wird ja die ganze welt
aus nachmacher bestehen oder nicht ich
meine justin bieber hat auch keine
dreadlocks empfohlen das wort von
afrikanern oder sonst wo er von keine
ahnung weil das ist ja ist ja auch
scheißegal ich will mich da auch nicht
zu weiter äußern so leute jetzt musste
ich kurz aufstehen und mich wieder
hinsetzen
denn jetzt kommen wir zu dem
einzigartigsten dem nicht am meisten
gelesenen kommentar und auch wirklich
den sinnvollsten kommentar unter dem
ganzen video und zwar schreibt gegen
seinen carlo
die abo ich stelle mir so vor carlo ist
auf youtube unterwegs und sucht coole
youtuber zum abonnieren
youtube alter gebäude höre dann
natürlich sofort barbuda war waffen das
denn für eure du bist scheiße verpasst
sich von von youtube wo deine video
video sind schlägt wegen deiner armen
kerl bist du ein [ __ ] man ja heute also
wenn ihr ein video dazu noch nicht
gesehen hab das einfach mal in der video
beschreibung verlinkt check das ab wir
sehen uns dann am
morgen wieder oder übermorgen keine
ahnung jetzt geht's auf jeden fall wie
gesagt ab mit videos das wetter will
wieder chance habe ich gehört ich habe
zeit ich habe bock wir sehen uns hat ein
daumen nach oben würde mich sehr freuen
aber nicht vergessen in sanaa
abschrecken hieß
auch wenn ihr meine haare dürfen aber
die werden besser